some fights don't end but they're still
worth fighting Doctor Who series 12
rolls on and we have arrived that can
you hear me I did something that I don't
do very often especially when I'm
watching something that I'm trying to
get the reviews out as its airing
because I want to turn these things
around relatively quickly I watched this
thing a second time before sitting down
to talk about it and I'm really glad I
did
vibe wise as far as an overall episode
it actually felt very reminiscent of it
takes you away this it has this sort of
odd approach to things you're not
entirely sure where it's going or what
it's playing at and it's borderline
surreal and it reminds me a lot more of
1970s era sci-fi not even necessarily
Doctor Who specifically but you know
things like a wrinkle in time and more
of the kind of expansion of the mind
style science fiction rather than the
usual spaceships and lasers kind and I
like when doctor who dips into that
there is a lot that I really really like
about this episode I think it does a
good sense of giving you a sense of sort
of a creeping threat that there's
because initially like we don't know
what's going on setup is straightforward
enough at first because we've caught
this woman in Aleppo she has these fears
she's seen things that nobody else sees
oh wait look they're real so okay
straightforward enough but then you know
the doctor brings everybody back to
Sheffield and they split for a bit and
people start having odd
things go on but they seem to be
incredibly self-contained they're less
odd events than they are odd personal
experiences as Ryan goes back and talks
to a friend who he's had for a long time
but he hasn't seen in a bit because of
the complications of travelling with the
doctor and y as you know sits down for a
dinner with her sister in remembrance of
something that we don't know right away
but there seems to be some baggage
behind that and then there's Graham who
gets this vision of this woman and we
don't know what any of this is is what
it has to do with the woman in Aleppo or
anything and I like the progression of
it I think this thing is very well paced
there's a very good job of laying out
what it is that we need to know but not
doing it any earlier than we need to
know it so I enjoyed all of that the
whole vibe is not quite at the level of
surreal but just off-putting enough that
you're like I'm a little unsettled and I
like it or at least that was my take
away with it so the way things
progressed from there was kind of why I
really needed to watch this twice so the
doctor encounters this guy this ancient
Baal tattoo had a guy who was haunting
Ryan's friend and showed up as you know
yaz saw him he seems to be orchestrating
this thing he seems to be whoever's
capturing this woman that Graham saw
first off I love that he's just
straight-up an immortal and something
way more powerful than the doctor is
it's actually been a really long time
since doctor who has acknowledged that
the Time Lords were not the end-all
be-all of intelligent life in the
universe in terms of achievements power
whatever else they just weren't that
even used to be at any rate new era
doctor who has really kind of
hammered that home which is contributes
the whole thing of the doctor herself
feeling like the most important thing in
the universe
part of that is caused by how much of a
buildup the Timelords themselves have
had you go back to classic error the
Timelords
they're up there but they're not running
everything there their upper middle
class is what they are but well above
them are these insane immortal beings a
lot of whom get name dropped by this guy
which I loved
he mentions the Eternals he mentions the
Guardians he mentions the Toymaker
that just that's just immediately where
my heart and I'd loved his attitude and
just this you know you know you're quite
clever and and all that but not enough
you're just way less impressive than me
that's just a fact and to have a guy
have that vibe where it just feels like
a natural fact it's not arrogance it's
like it's a reality he is more powerful
than her he is smarter than her at least
in terms of the initial setup and the
trap that he lays for her which is quite
a good trap in terms of both how he laid
it and what he was getting her to do and
I also dig the explanation that if he
comes from another dimension
he can't unlock this prison because it's
made from tech that just he can't work
this stuff and it especially feeds into
if all of his power and everything he
does feeds into mental states and dreams
and sort of so that's you know
manipulations of emotional or mental
states it's not tak he can't do anything
about the tech but the doctor can and
I'll I so I liked that and that we have
the release of the the other immortal
and initially I remember thinking first
time I watched it I found myself
thinking this is gonna have to be a
two-parter is it I mean the doctors
gonna take on immortal beings they're
not gonna wrap this up in the same
episode that would just completely
undermine the
and yet what it ended I didn't quite
feel that that had been the case and
that was again another one of the
reasons I needed to watch it again and I
needed to get a sense of what it was
that made it work part of it is that the
doctor didn't create a way to defeat
them from scratch she adapts what had
already been used to combat them this
prison she gets them back into it as
opposed to you know completely creating
from scratch a way to defeat effectively
gods in the narrative their gods the
matically metaphorically that's not what
they are they're depression they are
self-doubt they are the voices in your
head who torment you this episode does a
really good job of balancing the
metaphor that is going on with a story
that I think is interesting in and of
itself and even though I initially cited
it takes you away in terms of the
general vibe I think the lasting
impression that it gave me was something
much closer to Vincent and the doctor
I'm not sure it quite hits the same
highs at least in terms of the emotional
landing of everything but as far as
integrating the metaphor of depression
into the story yeah this is really good
and I I always love when theming can be
done as intelligently as this because
once you identify the theme of something
it begs a lot of questions well if this
represents that then does this work does
that work and whether or not it's good
theming the answer will either be yes or
no so for example with this once I hit
on these two the woman especially
because she just feeds on fear and bad
dreams and you know your nightmares
she even more than him is
depression is that that isolation and
everything that comes with it and I
found myself thinking well but the
doctor defeated them is that sending a
bad message about depression that you
can just beat it that you can just win
and I'm like no that it doesn't because
she doesn't obliterate them she doesn't
you know she doesn't render them
completely ineffective she doesn't take
their power away she traps them
she contains them they've been contained
before they've escaped before they could
escape again because that is depression
that is mental illness that is the
battle there isn't a cure for mental
conditions there's getting a handle on
it and hoping that you keep it and the
integration of that into what we find
out about Yaz's history really well done
by the way getting the flashback of her
as a runaway and having an encounter
with the police woman and how meaningful
that was and then at the end her going
to see that woman to give her the 50
cent the fifty pence piece I choked up
at that mainly because of the other
woman's reaction because he has knocks
on door and says look I'm sure you don't
remember me and just immediately yes
been conned of course I do and when she
sees the coin she chokes up and I choked
up with her
and with Ryan and his friend and Ryan
recognizing that things weren't quite
right with his friend and his friend
being very look no it's fine it's fine I
don't want to talk about his fine
but Ryan being close enough with him
that he is able to connect a little bit
and pull him out of
the cage that he made for himself and
get him out to get help
this series is dealing with a lot of
message episodes orphan 55 was a message
episode practice was a message episode
this is a message episode of the ones
we've had so far this is by far the best
one because actually they've gotten
better every time
whereas orphan 55 was this clunky thing
that beat you over the head with its
message at the very friggin end of the
thing as opposed to having it woven
across it and practiced did it better by
having it be a recurring thing that was
going on across the episode but even
then it was like pretty good but here
it's not just about having the message
occur across the story it's about having
the message feed the themes and the
themes help determine the way the story
goes so that everything fits together so
that the themes work with the story and
the story enhances the themes and the
message of seeking help and of little
things making the difference of Ryan's
showing up with chips to get in which
gets his friend open the door to you
know this this woman just on this one
day on the job talking to someone who's
run away from home just having a
conversation and it makes a difference
because it can it won't always you can't
save everyone some people don't want to
be saved some people they can't save
themselves with or without help but if
you try and if you reach out like this
woman did with the ads like Ryan does
with his friend like in a roundabout way
Graham and the doctor do with each other
there is the chance at making that
connection of making that difference and
it doesn't suddenly mean everything's
better but turning things around starts
with a single step in the right
direction and you can encourage and
inspire people to take that first step
in the direction they need to be in a
better place and what I mentioned with
Graham and the doctor
Graham doesn't have anybody to talk to
so he talks to the doctor and I actually
feel like the doctor in her very
reserved way kind of opened up a little
to him about not being very good at this
and talking through something that she
normally just would have done said okay
so I'm gonna stand over here and I'm
gonna I'm gonna mess with some stuff at
the TARDIS and then I'm gonna think of
what I should have said a few minutes
ago alright and I feel like that without
was her letting Graham in about as much
as she probably is able and willing to
let anyone in right now I felt like I've
learned more about the doctor in the
last couple episodes this one especially
then I have in a while this doctor
anyway Whitaker's doctor I'm starting to
get her now I think and I'm really
really enjoying what I see and
especially here where it's fully
integrated she she wants them the hair
she stalks them when they're not there
and like borates herself for having a
conversation and forgetting that they're
not even there to hear her but when they
ask her questions she doesn't want to
answer them she wants to be alone and
she also wants the company
and that's the battle that's happening
for her and there's a battle inside the
heads of most of us and if you didn't
catch it that's what the two planets
that trapped these Eternals that's what
they were it's the war that you have
with yourself inside your own head
orchestrated by depression by anxiety by
whatever is knowing at you gets you to
fight yourself in your own head just
sits back and laughs but if you can have
your moments of clarity maybe on your
own maybe with professional help maybe
inspired by just a little thing that you
have with someone if you can have your
moments of clarity where you get
whatever going on your head to stop
fighting
then maybe you can contain what it is
that's causing that battle and maybe
it'll break out again but maybe you can
contain it again when you need to maybe
it would help maybe on your own I don't
know but this was really good this I
think this has a really good shot at
being my new favorite episode of this
era of Chibnall and Whitaker I thought
it was a good story well told from a
narrative perspective and when you bring
the the thematic resonance to it this
was this was phenomenal I loved this
can you hear me also the perfect title
for this thing cuz we always wonder am I
actually being heard if you want to be
heard
awkward segue whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it
you can support what I do on my patreon
page there's a link in the description
there's the usual things like subscribe
they helped me out they helped me keep
drawing the channel you don't have to do
any of it though I'm not gonna tell you
what to do but I'll do my best to hear
you because at the end of the day you're
the council I'm just running meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]